nato is alarmed about russia's military
buildup on ukraine's borders and foreign
ministers from the alliance are meeting
today in latvia to discuss a response
about a month ago the u.s reported that
russian troops were gathering in large
number in several cities near the
russian border with belarus and ukraine
russia says it is entitled to station
its troops on its territory and they
pose no threat but nato and ukraine say
moscow may be preparing to launch an
attack
russian troops near the ukraine border
in early november
the u.s called it unusual activity and
raised alarm over a possible invasion
ukraine responded with its own show of
force
military exercises in its border region
[Music]
we have complete control over our
borders
and we are fully prepared for any
escalation
nato pledges its support to ukraine and
is warning against russian aggression
it is also clear that if russia uses
force against ukraine
that will have costs that will have
consequences
and therefore we continue to call on
russia to de-escalate
tensions are rising between russia and
the west over kiev's renewed bid to join
the nato military alliance
for the kremlin any expansion of
military aid to ukraine is a red line
we can't ignore these threats to the
security of russia
we will react to them as appropriate
adequately to the situation
ukraine already had a war scare with
russia earlier this year in april russia
deployed tens of thousands of troops
aircraft and missiles within striking
distance of ukraine moscow called it a
military exercise and after weeks of
posturing said the troops were being
withdrawn
western military experts say the
maneuvers this november were less
visible perhaps on purpose
we don't have clarity into
moscow's intentions but
we do know it's playbook
what ukraine and the west fear is a
repeat of 2014 when russian troops
entered ukraine followed by the
annexation of crimea
and a bloody war between russia-backed
separatists and ukrainian troops in the
eastern donbass region
despite several attempts at peace talks
it's a fight with no end in sight
dw's alexander fundament is in riga and
joins us for more on this story hi
alexander it's good to see you we
mentioned that nato foreign ministers
are meeting what kind of response could
we see from the alliance to this russian
troop build-up
nato secretary general stoltenberg told
us that the main goal right now is to
prevent any russian aggression against a
ukraine and
of course a key issue for nato is now to
strike a right balance of military
deterrence and diplomacy and saltenberg
told us that are still communication
channels that are open even though
russia has suspended its mission to nato
so both sides are talking but there are
of course other options of on the table
more military aid for ukraine for
example or more weapon systems that is
nothing that nato as an alliance would
do but some
nato allies could consider providing
ukraine with more military aid and
weapons just think what the us is doing
they have already delivered anti-missile
thing
anti-tank
missiles and the past to ukraine so all
of that is here on the table and i think
that everyone knows here that nato needs
to craft an approach that
neither appeases russia nor causes
further or provokes further tensions
well russia says that these talks of an
attack are just u.s propaganda i mean
why do nato members fear and evade an
invasion of ukraine is here on the cards
there are incredible
intelligence reports saying that russia
is moving its group its troops across
its territory that the kremlin is
amassing troops up to 94 000 soldiers at
the border with ukraine and nato is
saying that we are talking here about
tanks artillery
electronic warfare systems and of course
no one knows what
putin is planning and as you said the
kremlin is denying that they are
planning an invasion but we have to
consider russia's track record in the
region the annexation of crimea in 2014
russia's support for separatists in the
eastern ukraine so nato nato is very
concerned
alexander if an invasion were to take
place jen stoltenberg has said there
will be consequences there will be costs
what would those be
well i asked him
just exactly the same question yesterday
and he didn't want to elaborate just
saying that we should consider what nato
has already done
what they did after 2014 they increased
their presence on nato's eastern flank
uh we have four battle groups in the
baltic states and in poland and they
were sanctions imposed against russia
but the question of course is what
really they can do and how important
ukraine is for the alliance and what
options could be on the table that's
what
nato foreign ministers are going to
discuss here in riga
alexander fundamental reporting there
for us from riga thank you very much
you